my belief is that money is a product
just like anything else and I think we
will not have truly pure capitalism and
truly pure free markets until money
which is a product that we utilize which
is a product which is a half of every
single transaction in our society is
something that is originates from the
free market as well
I believe that money is ultimately a
product of the market rather than a
product of the state and I think the
last forty seven years in history have
sort of are a temporary phenomena for
thousands of years gold was the
predominant money or gold and silver
were the predominant two currencies
around the world until sort of the paper
notes became more widespread as a
technology you can think of paper notes
as a layer to technology on top of money
on top of monetary metals and at that
point once you had paper notes which
sort of were redeemable for metals there
was no longer the divisibility problem
of gold was solved so the need for solar
was drastically reduced and thus silver
was demonetised further it's very
interesting to look at the gold silver a
sort of price ratio and after 1881 you
see sort of gold skyrocket in silver
terms but I believe that something
similar will happen with Bitcoin versus
all other monetary instruments and even
other financial assets which is really
which is really quite eerie I think that
when all is said and done Bitcoin will
be the second or the third single
biggest asset class the single biggest
asset in the world
maybe real-estate will be the only one
bigger and sort of this is my reasoning
around this right now it is believed
that the total money supply of all fiat
currencies around the world is somewhere
around 80 trillion dollars mmm
if you consider M 1 M 2 M 3 or if you
add them all up around the world and I
strongly believe that that number is
artificially diluted and artificially
kept small because essentially by
continuously printing governments are
disincentivizing the world and this
incentivizing investors and even average
people to store or too much money in
currencies and they're doing this
because if I take a hundred dollars and
I put my bank account as they print
money that $100 loses purchasing power
every single year for sure I mean every
single day where the money creation
occurs see it's interesting because the
cost of creating that money for the
government is near zero it all it takes
is just a per PI push of a button right
but essentially every single unit of
fiat currency that gets created reduces
the wealth of the Fiat holder around the
world and bitcoin is an unimaginably new
phenomena where for the first time
nobody can seize your wealth not just
directly like they did with gold in the
30s but just like they do with stealth
inflation in fiat nobody can print more
and for the first time you have this
currency that you can have full or at
least very strong confidence that for
the rest of your life the percentage of
the money supply of this entire system
will always remain the same which really
is completely unprecedented because even
with gold you don't have that